la pareja de acá tiene a dos individuos
que tienen un ingreso al que se le puede
aplicar un impuesto de 100 mil cada uno
lo que quiero que pensemos primero es
analizar cuánto tendría que pagar de
impuestos cada uno de ellos si fuera una
persona soltera así que veamos los
tabuladores individuales de este lado
sacamos nuestra calculadora para
encontrar la cantidad para cada uno de
ellos los primeros ocho mil 925 dólares
tendrán una tasa del 10 por ciento y si
lo redondeamos serán 800 93 dólares y
después el siguiente incremento de 8 mil
925 hasta 36 mil 250 se le va a aplicar
el 15 por ciento cuyo redondeo da 4099
todo lo que está entre paréntesis son
cálculos que yo ya he hecho con
anterioridad más el incremento de 36 mil
250 87 mil 850 que es aproximadamente 12
mil 900 cuya tasa del 25 por ciento es
aproximadamente 12 mil 912 mil 900 y
finalmente el incremento por encima de
87 mil ochocientos cincuenta
usted es esencialmente el tabulador en
el que cae cada uno de estos individuos
y este incremento tendrá una tasa del 28
por ciento de impuestos lo escribimos
más punto 28 por el ingreso 100.000
menos el límite inferior 87 1850 dejamos
que tengamos la cantidad correcta de
ceros
ok son 100.000 menos 87 1850
cerramos paréntesis y nos da como
resultado 21 mil 294 dólares y eso es lo
que cada uno pagaría individualmente
pero esta es una pareja así que vamos a
combinar esto multiplicando por dos y
nos va a quedar 42.588 así que si hacen
su declaración como individuos no sé a
lo mejor no están casados simplemente
están viviendo juntos
bueno el impuesto que tendrían que pagar
entre los dos es de 42 mil 588 dólares
así que la combinación de ellos de
manera individual será de 42 mil
588 dólares ahora veamos cuánto tendrían
que pagar como un matrimonio con una
pareja casada ya que es el caso de que
una vez casados se van a pagar más
impuestos por los ingresos que se tengan
y este matrimonio tiene ingresos
combinados de 200 mil ahora vamos a
analizar los tabuladores de matrimonio o
de declaración conjunta incluso aunque
ustedes estén casados y hace su
declaración como individuos los
fabuladores serán la mitad de los
tabuladores que tenemos aquí así que
resulta económicamente equivalente
siempre y cuando cada individuo de la
pareja tenga el mismo ingreso ahora
veamos el escenario de matrimonio de
esta pareja sacamos de nuevo nuestra
calculadora y la hacemos un lado para
ver los tabuladores de matrimonio los
primeros 17 1850 tienen una tasa del 10
por ciento de impuestos que es
redondeado 1785 aquí tengo la cantidad
en paréntesis de cuál es el 10 por
ciento de este rango y a lo mejor
ustedes ya se dieron cuenta que estos 2
tabuladores son el doble de estos
tabuladores de aquí
la idea general es que ahora se tienen
dos personas y esencialmente tienen el
doble de ingreso y esto continúa hasta
que llegamos a este punto de acá y ese
es el objetivo de este vídeo ver si las
parejas casadas pagan más impuestos que
las personas solteras que viven juntas
veamos entonces cuánto está pagando esta
pareja como casada así que escribimos de
los primeros 17 1850 el 10% es mil 785
más el incremento hasta 72 mil 500 que
se le aplica el 15 por ciento y es
aproximadamente 8 mil 188 dólares
después del incremento hasta 146 mil 400
que tiene una tasa del 25 por ciento
cuyo cálculo previo es de 18 mil 475
y se me fue un más extra lo quitamos y
finalmente analizamos el último
tabulador donde queremos ver la cantidad
que está por encima de 146 mil 400 al
que se le aplica una tasa del 28 por
ciento de la diferencia de el ingreso
combinado 200 mil
- el límite inferior que 146 mil 400
dólares
y con esto tenemos unos impuestos
combinados de 43 mil 456 dólares lo
escribimos aquí como pareja casada van a
pagar 43 mil 456 de hecho aquí son no
casados porque estamos hablando de las
parejas y casados muy bien resulta que
casados pagan más impuestos que no
casados así que esta pareja que gana
bastante bien que tiene el mismo ingreso
por separado pagaría menos impuestos si
no estuvieran casados que los que tienen
que pagar ya estando casados y aquí la
cuestión es que caemos en este tabulador
que se incrementa de manera más rápida
que el tabulador que está de este lado
que es lo que se tendría que pagar de
manera individual o por los ingresos de
una persona soltera aquí llegamos más
rápido este tabulador y por eso llegamos
a esta tasa que se aplica a la mayor
parte de su ingreso combinado así que
cuando las personas hablan de la sanción
al matrimonio es a esto a lo que se
refieren
sanción
matrimonio
ya que casados tienen que pagar más
impuestos básicamente es un impuesto por
estar casados ahora exploremos si es que
siempre hay una sanción al matrimonio
resultará que siempre se van a pagar
menos impuestos al no estar casados que
al estar casados veamos la pareja ve
aquí no tienen el mismo ingreso aunque
el ingreso combinado es la misma
cantidad así que si vemos el tabulador
del matrimonio y declaración conjunta
van a tener la misma cantidad de
impuestos que pagar que la pareja
anterior van a tener que pagar 43 mil
456 que esto corresponde a la pareja ve
pero ahora analicemos cuánto tendrían
que pagar cada uno de ellos por su parte
si no estuvieran casados sacamos de
nuevo la calculadora y lo primero que
tenemos que ver sobre el primer elemento
de la pareja que recibe un ingreso al
que se le aplica impuestos de 180 mil
dólares va a pagar el 10 por ciento de
los primeros 8 mil 925 que es 893
y después tenemos que va a pagar 15 por
ciento de lo que esté por encima de 8
mil 925 que ya calculamos que es 4 mil
99 lo escribimos a esto le agregamos lo
del siguiente tabulador que es 12 mil
y al final sumamos el 28 por ciento de
la cantidad que se encuentra por encima
de los 87 1850 esta persona gana 180 mil
casi llega el límite superior pero vamos
a calcular la diferencia punto 28 por
180.000
- 87 1850
y nos queda que este miembro de la
pareja va a pagar 43 mil 694 dólares de
forma individual y a esto lo tendremos
que agregar los impuestos que paga el
otro miembro de la pareja y esta persona
va a pagar el 10 por ciento de los
primeros ocho mil novecientos 25 893 más
vamos a ver la diferencia y a ésta se le
va a aplicar el 15 por ciento punto 15
por 20 mil menos 8 mil 925
cerramos paréntesis y esto nos da que
este miembro de la pareja va a tener que
pagar dos mil 554 dólares con 25
centavos de impuestos si lo agregamos al
impuesto que tiene que pagar la otra
pareja o el otro miembro de la pareja le
sumamos 43 mil 694 van a tener que pagar
un total de 46 mil 248 dólares con 25
centavos lo redondeamos a lo escribo
aquí arriba 46 mil 248 esto es la suma
de los impuestos que tendría que pagar
cada uno de manera individual y estos
son los impuestos que tienen que pagar
ambos como matrimonio y aquí vemos un
escenario diferente aquí los impuestos
más grandes se encuentran cuando ellos
no están casados 46 mil 248 y pagar
menos impuestos si estuvieran casados en
esta situación lo que se obtiene es un
beneficio
el matrimonio
por qué sucede esto bueno ustedes pueden
notar que ambas personas de acá tienen
un ingreso bastante alto y tienen
ingresos similares o iguales en cambio
aquí aunque ambos individuos tienen un
ingreso combinado igual que la pareja
anterior sus ingresos individuales son
diferentes así que lo que sucede es que
cuando esta persona declara sus
impuestos individuales va a llegar a el
último tabulador de manera muy rápida y
esta persona pues casi no está pagando
impuestos pero la mayoría de los
impuestos vienen de esta persona al
casarse y combinarse en una sola entidad
este individuo es quien va a ser más
beneficiado ya que aquí él solito
tendría que pagar casi todos los
impuestos correspondientes a los 200.000
pero combinados van a ir pasando de un
tabulador a otro de manera más lenta así
que para cuando llegan al tabulador del
28% van a tener una cantidad mucho más
pequeña aquí tendría una fracción un
poco mayor a la que se le aplica el 25%
gran una fracción mucho más grande a la
que se le aplica el 10% comparado
especialmente a este individuo de acá
con los tabuladores individuales así que
si tienen una pareja que tiene un alto
ingreso al que se le aplica en impuestos
es muy probable que obtengan una sanción
al matrimonio o que lo vean como una
sanción al matrimonio su declaración
conjunta si tenemos una pareja cuyos
salarios son muy diferentes aunque sus
salarios combinados son altos es muy
probable que obtengan beneficios al
matrimonio ahora veamos la pareja y
quiero que aquí ustedes reflexionen un
poco en este ejemplo aquí tenemos
salarios iguales en eso se parecen a la
pareja pero su sueldo combinado o su
ingreso combinado no es muy alto si se
fijan en los tabuladores de declaración
conjunta ellos caerían en este tabulador
y noten que hasta este punto todos los
tabuladores son el doble que
corresponden a los tabuladores
individuales así que vamos a ir
exactamente igual de lentos
uno de los tabuladores aquí de lo que
iríamos acá aquí como tenemos que las
dos personas ganan exactamente lo mismo
pues tendremos la misma cantidad de
impuestos en el tabulador del 10% en el
del 15% y en el del 25% y los invito a
que ustedes hagan esos cálculos ya que
son una buena práctica
al final verán que estos dos individuos
pagan exactamente los mismos impuestos
ya sea como individuos sin casarse o
como una pareja casada estos van a ser
iguales no importa si están casados o no
ya que su ingreso combinado no es lo
suficientemente grande como para llegar
al tabulador en donde el impuesto se
incrementa mucho más rápido espero que
esto les haya ayudado a comprender este
concepto y nos vemos en el siguiente
vídeo